[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Hi, everyone.
Really excited to be in LA and
bringing you this amazing panel
this afternoon.
I'll start by introducing them,
before we get into the really
rich conversation.
Immediately to my right, I
have Dr. Rhonda Gonzalez,
Associate Professor of African
and African Diaspora History
and Associate Vice Provost
for Strategic Initiatives
and Director of
Pivot for Academic
Success at the University
of Texas at San Antonio.
Next to Dr. Gonzalez
is Andrew Herrera,
founder of Remezcla.com, one
of the most influential media
companies focused on
Latino millennials.
And to his right is JC Polanco--
Juan-Carlos, but
we'll call him JC,
is a former Bronx Commissioner
and President of New York City
Board of Elections he is
attorney for Polanco Law
and teaches Latino Studies at
Borough of Manhattan Community
College in New York City.
And next to JC is America
Ferrera, an amazing actress,
who we love for her work on
"Ugly Betty," "Sisterhood
of Traveling Pants"
and so much more.
She's now starring on NBC's
hit show, "Superstore,"
which I mentioned to her
that my eight-year-old
daughter watches.
Because we love having strong
Latino figures to watch.
And she and her
husband, Ryan Piers,
recently launched an org called
Harness, bringing artists
together to create change.
Please join me in welcoming
our panelists this afternoon.
[APPLAUSE]
This series aims to have open
and constructive conversations
on race and capturing the full
breadth of being Hispanic,
or Latinx, in
America, incorporates
notions of race, ethnicity,
culture, language, emotive
attachments and
affiliations, for starters.
Defining the Hispanic
Latino identity is complex.
With all of that
in mind, I'd like
to start by asking
our panelists,
what does it mean to be
Hispanic, Latinx in the US,
and what is a responsible way
to grapple with that complexity?
AMERICA FERRERA: I
guess I'll start.
I just learned
that I'm a Latinx.
I just learned that term.
I didn't really know what it
meant until someone told me.
And, you know, I mean,
I can really only
speak for my own personal
experience and the sort
of anecdotal experiences
and conversations
I've had with other
Latino Americans.
It is-- for me, it's
been one of the biggest
questions of my life.
I was born in Los Angeles,
raised in the San Fernando
Valley to immigrant parents.
And I grew up mainly
surrounded by Jewish people.
So a big, big part of me
feels Jewish, culturally.
Never went to a
single quinceanera--
tons of bar and bat mitzvahs.
And I remember going
to school, and most
of the Latinos I would encounter
were bused in from downtown.
And I had been sort of--
through family, through
culture, through just observing
the world around me--
kind of conditioned to
think of myself as outside
of that Latino.
You know?
I wanted to be
academically successful.
I wanted to be top of my class.
I wanted to succeed.
I had big ambitions.
And everything and everyone
around me, you know,
reminded me that I couldn't
be that kind of Latino
if I wanted to be
and do the things I
wanted to do in the world.
And so a lot of my
young Latino identity
really had a lot to do
with neglecting and denying
my Latino identity.
And that was a really,
really complicated thing.
To find success as an actress,
be immediately labeled
and deemed a Latina
actress, held up
as a representative of
the Latino community,
when my dirty, dirty secret
on the inside was like,
I don't know what it means,
to me, to be a Latina.
And so I had to go on
that journey for myself
to figure that out and
give myself the permission
to claim my Latino identity
and to define it for myself.
And while every young Latino
or Latinx's experiences
is quite different, what I
think is the common thread, when
you're a Latin American,
is that you're sort of--
you're charged with this
question of are you an American
or are you a Latina?
And what is the line?
And how much of you is this?
And how much of you is that?
And what I can say is
that, you can't be a Latinx
without having to ask yourself
those questions almost
on a daily basis.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO:
Thanks for sharing that.
[INAUDIBLE] would
you like to go next?
I'm sorry, I saw you
go to your microphone.
RHONDA GONZALEZ: You go first.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: That's
a very interesting story.
Thanks for sharing that.
I think that to be Latino is
something so exciting today.
It really is.
It's an exciting
time to be Latino.
I feel it in my soul.
I mean, every time I
pick up a newspaper,
every time I go online,
every time I turn the TV on,
there is something happening.
There is a discussion
as to, how can we
bring this incredible group
of people into the fold?
How can we
communicate with them?
How can we connect them?
How can we get them
to vote for us?
Which is where I'm coming from.
We really need that vote!
I mean, you look at
the numbers of what
it means to be Hispanic, nearly
25% of all babies born today
have some sort of Latin
American background to them.
So it's an exciting
time to be Hispanic.
It's an exciting group to cover.
I teach the history of
the Dominican Republic
at the Borough of
Manhattan Community College
as well as the Latino
experience in the United States.
And my classes are
filled to capacity.
People of all different races
and ethnicities and backgrounds
are coming in because
they want to learn
more of what this dynamic
group of people are all about.
One thing that many
of them don't know
is that it's very complicated
to answer, even as a professor
standing before them.
What is a Latino?
What is a Latino supposed to be?
What does a Latino look like?
What kind of a racial
background does a Latino claim?
And it is something that
is very complicated,
and it's something that I
think needs to be understood.
It needs to be appreciated.
It needs to be read about.
And you need to
somehow delve yourself
in the history of Latin American
United States relations.
I think that it's
important for people
like President Trump,
and people in the House
of Representatives, as we
talked earlier, people in the US
Senate, to stop for a
minute to really study
the history of what it
is to be a Latin American
and understand the United States
involvement in Latin America.
To understand how we
came to be, and to see
the complicated issues
that exist today
are not just about
talking points.
They really affect people, and
they're historical in nature.
So to be Hispanic, to be
Latino, is to have the burden--
once you're cognizant of
our history and cognizant
of what we are-- it's to
have the burden of knowing
that your ancestors
were rapists,
and murderers, people that
enslaved millions of people.
It is also to feel
the tragedy of knowing
that your ancestors were
the enslaved ones-- were
the people that were
raped, were the people
that were brought
here in shackles.
It is having the anger to know
that your people's lands were
taken.
It is to feel the
resentment inside your soul.
To know that your
ancestors, at one point,
experienced genocide.
And it's having all
of that combined.
That once you really
appreciate what
it is to be Hispanic--
once you get closer
and closer to
understanding, you begin
to see how you can
become bipolar.
You can have this
resentment within yourself
and appreciation of yourself.
And the reason I'm so
excited is because we
have some panelists here
that have been focused
a great deal on
this issue, bringing
this issue to the forefront.
I'm excited to hear
what they have to say.
I'm really excited to be
part of the group here today.
Because we have so many--
so much diversity.
We have blacks, we have
whites, we have Chinese,
we have mulattoes, like me.
We have hair of every texture.
We have transgender, we
have gay, we have lesbian,
we have straight.
We have those that don't
identify or conform.
So it's an exciting
time, and that's
why I'm so happy to
be here, and hope
we get to talk more about it.
So thank you again
for having me.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
ANDREW HERRERA: Awesome.
Well, you know, I think it's--
probably, like everyone said,
it's a very complex question.
And I don't think
there's one answer.
I think there's several answers.
You know, the term
Latinx is something
that has become kind
of in vogue in terms
of how to describe this
community over the last year,
year and a half.
I think, in the political
environment, actually,
even become even a more common
way to describe this community.
I think first we've got to
look back at why that is.
I think, you know,
we've been trying to--
first, you know, I think I
grew up in the '90s, and a lot
of times it was about kind
of people calling you--
you know, identifying
you as Spanish,
but you're not Spanish.
You know, I'm not from Spain.
I'm an Ecuadorian
kid from Queens.
Then, as you get
older, it's about,
are you Latino or Hispanic,
and what does that mean?
And then today, now when
we talk about Latinx,
I don't think it's
about necessarily trying
to define this
group, but actually
embrace this complexity.
Because it is evolving.
I think, you know, I heard a
lot about kind of the history.
And I think history is
something we should understand,
but we shouldn't
have it be what I
guess narrows our thinking
about what, you know, Latinidad,
or what being Latino is today.
It's something that is
continually evolving,
the same way being
American 100 years ago
feels different than it
is to be American today.
I think that's how we look
at Latinos, or our Latinx
community.
We're going to be
continually evolving.
RHONDA GONZALEZ: That's great.
So I think America and
JC and Andrew, what
I hear in their conversation
is this real threat
of both the individual journey
and also a national journey.
And then I hear a racial
journey, as well, right?
So all those kind of identities.
And I think that that
really does underscore,
in part, the complexity of it.
And then much of it-- at
least in the way I see it,
and to just back up a little
bit and give a little bio.
I grew up just down
the street from here,
in Long Beach, California.
And I grew up in a predominantly
African-American community,
for the most part, and
in my earliest years
felt at least an affinity.
You know, when you
grow up around friends.
But, you know,
along that journey,
I too encountered the reality
that people sort of create
paradigms that we
enter into, or we
get read through these lenses
that we didn't necessarily
construct.
And so we're constantly aware
of negotiating all of that.
And also, I think
in some ways wanting
to play a role in
making sure that we
are constructing the ongoing--
to use your term--
evolving history.
So we become part of the people
who construct what that means.
So I think the largest
still in our nation,
like thinking about
the demographic shifts
in the nation and
knowing that we
are becoming more and more
Latinx, Latino, Hispanic.
And there's a conversation
in there, by the way,
to have as well.
Chicana.
I think we should
put that out there.
Is that the changing
demographics demand, really,
and really require us to
think about the real binary we
work in within the nation.
So that I think--
I'd love to hear
the other panelists,
but I think that a lot of
us in the center, brown folk
really do work within
the black white binary.
We live within it, and we see
that very dominant conversation
happening.
And then we enter it and
we're kind of like, you know,
we're here!
We're not quite maybe what you
think of as black identified
or white identified, but there's
a whole spectrum that we cover.
And I think in part of moving
forward with the nation,
we really do have to reckon
with that conversation
and conscientiously realize that
the binaries we live within,
whether they are gender--
which we're really thinking
about today more than ever.
We all have to think about race
and what the role of colorism
has meant in not just
Latino communities,
but across communities.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you so much.
There's so much to
uncover from everything
that you've all shared.
I want to touch several
points that you just
made, Rhonda, but I want
to touch on the labels
and how we identify ourselves.
America, you started
by saying you just
found out you're Latinx.
I grew up in the
Dominican Republic,
and I became Hispanic when
I moved to the States.
You know?
So a lot of us are grappling
with identities that are
evolving and shifting often.
So Latinx, Hispanic, Chicana,
Latino, Latin American.
What is the term, if
there is only one?
And when you speak of it,
what are the terms that you
recommend to others?
How do you identify
yourself, and how do you
speak to others about what
these terms and labels mean?
ANDREW HERRERA: We'll
go to you, America.
AMERICA FERRERA: I
have to start again?
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Let's start over here now.
AMERICA FERRERA: Let's
start with the professors.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW HERRERA: Sure.
You know, I don't think--
I don't know if
that's fair, right?
I think it means something
different to each individual.
I think, you know, I
started a publication that
was focused on breaking
stereotypes around culture
and showing the evolution
and the emerging
side of Latin culture.
And as this has
grown over time, we
see that people are coming up
with new references in terms
of how they view their
generation in this community.
So I think it means different
things to different people.
And, for example,
editorially, you know, I--
we don't call everything
Latinx, right?
We look at how people
identify themselves.
And this is an
argument that I think
we see when we write articles.
And I think, you know, the
same way America talked about--
she just learned about Latinx--
there is a little
bit of a frustration
with a certain
generation of not wanting
to be identified as Latinx.
Because they don't
understand it.
And so I think it's not
fair to kind of force people
to take on a term
about who they are,
whether they were
Hispanic for one decade,
and then Latinos for another,
and Latinx in this era.
So I think we need to allow
it to continue to evolve.
And, you know, there's--
I run a company with
people that come
to work because they are looking
to find a place where they're
not trying to be defined.
But their complexity
is part of kind
of the mission of the company.
So whether you're--
I think, in the past, we
would look at last names
as a way to identify whether
someone was Hispanic.
But now you have
people that, you know,
you could be Amanda Jones,
but you could actually
be a Colombian or a Mexican.
And so I think we
need to break away
from trying to kind
of, I think, answer
questions in this way, that try
to define a group in one way.
So, you know, I think allowing
people to create terms.
I think it's not about one.
I think it's about probably
having an infinite amount
of terms that allow
people to communicate
their individualism.
And that's what we--
I think as a
community, we almost
need to get out of
having these labels.
Because I think it is a
certain form of conditioning.
Whether it be a census
form, or whether it
be identifying whether you are
part of a race or ethnicity,
I think it's something that is
not in the hands of, you know,
someone else.
It's something that
comes from within.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Centering on
your own individual identity.
ANDREW HERRERA: Yeah.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: I think--
that's interesting.
I think labels are important.
I think we use the term
labels, and somehow we
want to take away
from how important
what you identify as is.
It's not just a word that
you just throw around.
When you claim a word and you
identify as what you believe
that word to be, it matters.
It means something.
There's a lot of
meaning behind it.
So I'm very concerned.
Because I think that
these labels are
so important that when
you introduce new labels,
you tend to create
new identities,
or you create an environment
where the issues that
are affecting the people that
are grouped in that identity
have a situation where the
real issues that impact
them are diluted.
Today, we have
focused a great deal
on changing what we identify as.
So today-- there was a time
when you were Hispanic.
And you mentioned something
interesting about growing up
in the Dominican Republic.
I'm a Dominican
kid from the Bronx.
I thought I was Puerto Rican
till I was in fourth grade.
True story.
If somebody asked me, I'm
Boricua, I don't know.
Then somebody said,
wait a minute,
your parents are from
the Dominican Republic.
And then it gets even
funnier, because then
what do you identify as?
I'm a black and white Dominican.
And then as you become more
and more aware, you say,
I'm a mulatto!
And then some people
don't like that term,
but I'm a biracial Dominican.
And it's a really exciting
time, as I mentioned earlier.
But what's interesting
about the names
or how you identify yourself
as is that it matters.
So when I say to
you, I'm Latino,
and I pride myself on that.
And I say to myself, I'm
going to study what this means
and how these people
differ from others,
and what are the contributions
that we've made to this
country, and how are American
of Latino descent-- like I am--
how are we interesting?
What do we contribute
to our society?
It's important that
people have something
that they can rally around.
So I know that I'm in the
minority up here when I say--
and I hope I don't get
kicked off the panel--
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ: We
want diverse voices here, JP.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: When I say
I don't subscribe to Latinx,
I don't.
I don't subscribe to it.
I think that it dilutes the real
matters that we're focusing on.
| think Latinx is a cover for
the Hispanics in our community
who have a hard time
accepting the transgender
community or the non-gender
conforming community.
I think we have to address the
heart and soul of the matter.
You have to embrace
these people.
These people have been
hiding for centuries.
You have to embrace them.
These people are part
of us, and you're not
to discriminate
against these people.
Simply creating
an entire new term
and throwing "x" at the end--
which is, by the way,
an Americanized thing.
Throwing it in and now making it
part of Latinx to somehow force
people to recognize that not
everybody's gender conforming
I think is disingenuous.
I really do.
I think we have to
understand that we
have to change hearts
and minds and not
the letters in the word.
And Latinx, although
means well, I
think creates
divisions between us--
Latin Americans in
the United States--
and our counterparts that
are not in the United States.
And another issue I think
that is important about labels
is that there is
strength in numbers.
Today, we have millions
and millions of Latinos
that are of every race, and
every color, and every gender,
and every gender identity.
That it's important
that you recognize
why we do that politically,
as it is important.
Because if all of a sudden
tomorrow Hispanic leaders,
like many of the
people on this panel,
decide that we're going
to now call ourselves
by a specific ethnicity,
there won't be that strength.
There are only a million or
so Dominicans in the United
States, but there are millions
and millions and millions
of Latinos in the United States.
So creating further divisions
among a group that's already
divided on ethnic lines,
racial lines, religious lines,
at times, adds to the
issues that we face.
And including this as a
topic of conversation,
or making this a focal point,
truly dilutes of the fact
that 33% of the people in
federal prisons look like me
and have names like mine.
It dilutes the fact that 22%
of the people in our country
are in poverty, and almost
all of them look like me
and have last names like mine.
So let's focus on
those issues, instead
of fancying around the letter x,
which is an Americanized thing,
to the realities of
the issues that we're
facing in our community.
AMERICA FERRERA: I'm not sure
I understood all of that.
I need to take your
class, so that I can.
But what-- you
know, I think it's--
the thing that makes
us all uncomfortable,
which is contradiction
and dichotomy.
And how, yes,
labeling separates us.
But at the same time, if
you can't name something,
you can't face it.
You can't claim it,
you can't deal with it.
And this is
something that I feel
like I've been sitting with
and thinking about just
in the last couple of months
since the election is, how do I
claim my Latina-ness,
which is not
separate from my American-ness?
So as an American, I feel OK
using things that are American,
like adding x to
the end of a word.
Because I am fully American.
I was born and raised
in this country.
I consider myself an American.
And that was an
identity that I felt
stronger connected to way before
I understood my own Latino
identity.
So I don't think of
my Latino identity
as having to be purified
from my American identity
or separate from.
But I also-- what
I've been sitting with
is, how do I claim, and
protect, and make space
for my Latino identity, but
not let it keep me from all
my other experiences?
And I'm most concerned,
in this moment,
about how we start
widening the circles of how
we relate to one another.
You know, is my skin black?
No, but I relate to
the black experience.
Am I gay?
No, but I relate to the gay.
Am I trans?
No, but I relate to that.
I will stand for
that experience.
I will stand with those people.
And my heart is a part of
that battle, that struggle,
that fight, as well.
And so it is, to me, a real
uncomfortable conversation
to have about labels.
Because, on one hand, until
I could say to myself,
I'm a Latina, I am--
and that's going to mean to me
what I decide it means to me.
And I don't have to go around,
in my particular industry,
hiding the fact
that I'm Latina so I
can get this job, that
job, and this job.
Like being able to say that--
walk into a room, claim that,
be proud of that, know
that that's what I am,
and know that it shouldn't
stop me from the opportunity
and access that I so desire--
mattered to me.
And so I do think labels matter.
And I do think
identifying yourself
as certain things changes
how you are in the world.
And I think that there's
the contradiction of,
yes, there are ways and times
in which it separates us
from one another.
So I think it's--
I think it's more complicated
than just sort of dismissing
labels as a bad thing.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
Dr. Gonzales?
RHONDA GONZALEZ: OK.
So maybe I'm going
to take a little bit
of a different approach to it.
So I think-- over time, or
over the course of one's life,
I think in the United
States, because people
think about their journey
growing up-- there
is a tendency, maybe,
say, around youth?
Maybe from youth to start,
pushing back against labels
that they grew up with.
Categories they grew up with.
And I think that's
probably a rite of passage.
People embrace adolescence,
early adulthood.
And then they start to see their
worlds become more complicated
by other identities that are
already [INAUDIBLE] and in use.
But I think that--
I have a little bit of a
problem talking about labels.
Because what I really
think we're missing
here is the fact
that we're talking
about people who are trying
to name their position
of marginalization in society.
They're trying to draw attention
to the fact that, in some way,
their communities are
aggrieved, and that they
haven't had their foremost
concerns thought about.
And so whether or not somebody
embraces or pushes back
against a label I think
comes down to the individual.
And while I believe everybody's
individuality is important,
and that's part of an
American kind of sensibility,
I also think
collectively as a nation
we need to be thinking
about how these names are
about a collective ideology.
The way we are going
to reject, embrace
our thinking, our
inclusively, our empathy
for groups that really have
felt that they were on the outs.
And so-- and I don't think,
as maybe some on this panel
would argue-- that it's
about just coddling.
Because this is
serious business,
you know, the history
of the nation.
And so if we're
not really thinking
about how we are proactively
engaging with one another
and saying, OK,
maybe it's Latinx,
but what are we really
getting at with that?
What is undergirding
all of the emotion,
the structural barriers
and challenges,
or institutional barriers,
that come with that?
Right?
Or that inspire that.
So I think labels matter.
But more than that,
I think words matter.
And so there is a
very real reason
that words come to
be born for another--
you know, to use a metaphor.
There's a very reason.
And so I think that's what we
really need to think about.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Absolutely.
And thank you so much.
This is a dialogue
that could go on
for-- so I'm not going
to completely over invest
on the labels on the words.
But I do agree with you,
fundamentally, words do matter.
And the choice by which we
define ourselves and define
our place and our context
within this country does matter.
I'm going to speak a bit now
around the identity category.
Not just as a
label, but when you
think about the broader
construct of the Latin American
community, if you will.
So that is a group of people
from 26 different countries.
And different social
class backgrounds,
different immigrant journeys.
When data gets
collected on this group,
as we're discussing right now,
it's discussed as a monolith,
as a Latin American term.
What are the risks and
limits to doing so,
and what could be
alternative approaches
to highlight range and
variation within the community?
RHONDA GONZALEZ: May I go first?
OK.
Well, I think one of the basic
things that's a little bit
problematic and challenging for
us is that within those 26--
and I didn't know
there were 26--
is that class really matters.
So what is a starting point?
You know, for a family,
or individual, or group
that either has been
here for generations
or is newly arrived and
is in that category.
So I think understanding
the class reality
and how strikingly
different that is,
and how that also shapes
identity, is really important.
Also access to social
mobility or economic mobility.
And I think, you know, as
corporations-- and I mean,
I'm in an institution
of higher learning.
So, you know, we
think of ourselves
a little bit
differently invested
in the students who
come to our university.
I think as university leaders,
we need to think about all
of the heterogeneity
in the room.
Not just the Latino
heterogeneity--
race, ethnic, religious-- but
also their class diversity.
Because when you have a group
of people-- in this case,
students--
where their ability to
navigate through a system that
wasn't built for them,
in the case of a Hispanic
serving institution, which
the University of Texas at San
Antonio is, you have
a lot of students
who are arriving there.
And, for all intents
and purposes,
the institution is a
middle class environment.
And many of them arrive
there not middle class.
I mean, I'm a first
generation college student.
My mother has a third
grade education.
My father had an
eighth grade education.
So when I arrived at UCLA,
I was like, wow, this is--
and that was my first
experience with Jewish people.
I was like, what is this
salty donut thing they eat?
You know?
That's how I thought
about it when I got there.
You really have a
clash of cultures,
but also a class clash
of material history
that often happens.
And I think that, if we're
not aware of how different--
and maybe even some of
the employees in the room
have come from
these backgrounds,
and then you arrive on
this amazing campus.
And it's like so state of
the art, and all of this.
It's like, wow, you know,
I've never really maybe felt
like I belonged in
this environment.
And, you know, how am
I going to make sure
that this is part of my
home so that I can thrive,
and I can be as
creative and contribute
as much to this company
as I really want to?
And so I think the institution
of higher education
is similar in that way.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
Anyone else?
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO:
Well, I'll go.
I hope I was clear,
America and Dr. Gonzalez.
Labels matter, names
matter, and words matter.
I thought that was the theme.
It's just somehow, along
the line, I felt as if--
I didn't do a lot of debating.
And I felt as if I was facing
an opponent who countered
a position that I didn't make.
So I wanted to make sure that
I was clear with the audience,
as well.
I'm a firm believer
that names and labels
and how you identify matter.
Clearly.
So this is why this question
is so important as to--
because we come from all these
different classes and all
these different races,
how is it that--
what are some of the
risks that are involved?
I think there are a lot
of benefits with creating
a monolithic group.
There are.
And let me be very
honest with you guys.
There is an incredible
amount of benefit.
When you consider
that politicians
in this recent election were
talking about the Latino vote,
as if the Latino
vote was monolithic,
as if we all just agreed
on the same things,
and they view us as being
millions and millions
of people, then they're
going to cater to what is it
that the Latino people want?
You can't really quantify that.
You can't really quantify--
even at Google, what is it
that the Latino employees want?
That's a ridiculous question.
Because the Latino
employees are just
as diverse as the
non-Latino employees.
You know, us-- when I say
descendant of Latin America,
I'm talking about, our
parents are from there,
and we are Americans.
Because I claim American, and
it upsets a lot of people,
especially in New York.
Because when people come
up to me and ask me,
where are you from?
And I go, the Bronx, they're
like, no, no, no, seriously,
where are you from?
They want to know more
and more whether-- they
don't go to the white
guy and ask him that.
Because the white guy
gets around and says,
oh, I'm a quarter Italian,
quarter Irish, quarter German.
And by then, I'm just lost.
I don't even know how you divide
a human being in quarters.
So this idea is to--
the benefits that
are surrounded by just
calling us all Hispanic,
I think that there are a lot.
I think that we can take
advantage of that, politically.
Because politicians
in Washington
will have to think about things.
And I hope they do.
I know they're not right
now, and it really upsets me.
I hope they realize
that there are
issues that affect
all of us, regardless
of our ethnic background.
There are some issues
like immigration
that affect us as Latinos.
You may not be an
undocumented immigrant.
Your father may not
even be an immigrant.
You may be here for hundreds
of years, like the person
that I met earlier today.
But there are so many
differences between us
that it's very interesting
to see, how can you
unite all these people?
And when you say
Latinos, we have
something in common where
we could identify with.
And for the most part, we
have Spanish as a language
that many of us
can identify with.
And not that all of us
Latinos speak Spanish.
My kids don't.
But for the most part, we
have language that unites us,
and we also have a certain
immigration experience.
It may be now or it may have
been a couple of years ago.
And unlike so many of the
Chicanos, and you see labels
are important, right?
The Chicanos who have been
here for thousands of years,
in our territory here
in the United States.
So labels can matter now.
And how you identify Latinos
matters for purposes of power.
And if Hispanics,
or Latinos, begin
to understand the
importance of how there
are singular issues that
impact all of us, then
perhaps we'd be able to get
more power in Washington.
Perhaps President
Trump would think twice
before saying some
of the things,
and how he says some of
the things, about people
that affect us.
I'll tell you this.
On June 16th, 2015--
as a Republican, and
this was very hard--
I became a never
Trump Republican.
Because Donald Trump came down
those escalators and blasted
undocumented immigrants.
Blasted Mexicans, in particular.
Now I'm not Mexican.
I know a couple of Mexicans
in New York, but I'm not.
But when he did that,
I felt insulted.
I felt like, my people
just got dissed!
On TV!
We're murderers, and rapists,
and we're not the best?
And it bothered me,
but I had nothing--
if you look down
my ancestry DNA,
you're going to find
Mexican anywhere.
But I felt an affinity.
I felt a bond.
I felt an allegiance
to these people.
So there are some very
good things that happened.
And I was very angry about that.
Because, when he
did that, he really
castigated an entire
group of people.
When he did that about
the Mexican people,
I knew that he was
thinking about me.
AMERICA FERRERA: Of course.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO:
I knew that.
I knew he was thinking
about me, and he
was thinking about us up here.
AMERICA FERRERA: He doesn't
know the difference--
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: I know.
I know he was, and
it bothers me, a lot.
A lot.
And I wish I could talk to him,
but because I was never Trump,
I'm not allowed near Washington.
[LAUGHTER]
Anywhere near it.
But there are some advantages
for knowing the differences,
and this is why I get excited.
Once you realize that the Latin
American experience is very
similar to the so-called
American experience,
and that our history--
and I know Dr. Gonzalez
as a historian.
She'd appreciate this.
Our history is very similar.
It is.
We had a slave experience
in the United States.
in Latin America.
We had a European
conquest in North America.
We had the same thing
in South America.
We have a class structure
based on race in North
America for the most part.
Not always, but
it just so happens
to be that the wealthiest
are of a certain class,
of a certain race.
And then you go to Latin
America, especially
in the Caribbean, very similar.
The percentage of
the class elites,
or all of the
European descendancy,
and the great majority of the
people in poverty, are not.
So there are a lot
of similarities.
And I think once it becomes more
common for non-Latino students
to enroll in Latino
studies classes,
and to learn about
what Dominicans are,
and Puerto Ricans
are, and Mexicans
are, and know how important
the Mexican community has
been in the United States--
how 63% of our population that
is Hispanic is Mexican.
When you study the
contributions that they
made to civil rights--
although not as covered as the
African-American civil rights
movements, and I understand
the frustration for some--
you'd appreciate, have
a sense of appreciation.
And that's I continue to
say, if our politicians,
and our leaders take an
opportunity just read a book,
or have a discussion with
one of our panelists,
they'd think twice before
saying some of the things
that they've done and said.
And I'll say one more thing.
America, I'm sorry that
I'm taking so much time.
And I hate to beat
up on my own guys.
But Senator Sessions on
the floor of the US Senate
in 2006--
not in some club,
not during lunch,
on the floor in 2006 said
that-- and I'm paraphrasing--
that immigrants from
the Dominican Republic
have nothing to
offer our economy.
Because of that, they have
nothing to contribute.
It broke my heart.
It devastated me.
I said, well, how can that be?
How could it be
that the only thing
they identify with
Dominican-Americans
is baseball?
How don't they know about
Junot Diaz or Julia Alvarez?
Do they not understand the
contributions that we've made?
Or even Oscar de La Renta?
You can go down the list
and study how that's
an awful statement to make.
That man today is the attorney
general of the United States.
And I blame the
fact that we don't
talk enough about
our contributions
to the United States, and we
don't hold people to account.
To learn about our struggle.
To learn about what we've
done, what we've overcome,
and what we have contributed.
So I think they--
I know I spoke too long.
I'm sorry, America.
But I think it's
important that I'm clear.
Because when I'm
not clear, I panic.
So I want to make
sure that I'm clear.
[LAUGHTER]
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ: We're
going to avoid you panicking,
JC, but are going to
move over to America now.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: When
I heard America tackle me,
I said, America, you're
beating me up for no reason!
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ: America?
AMERICA FERRERA: I'm passionate!
I'm-- am I allowed to say this?
I'm Latina!
Yes.
What do you expect?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMERICA FERRERA: That's a
stereotype I get to use, right?
Own it.
This is something
that we are constantly
talking about inside of
the entertainment industry.
Because everybody
wants to know, how
do you get the Latino market?
How do you get
the Latino market?
And there's so much nuance
lost in that mindset.
You know, I think there's an
importance differentiating
diversity of race and
diversity of experience.
And, you know-- and
both have value.
And if a Latino, any Latino,
is dehumanized and ridiculed
by anyone, much less someone
running for president,
it hurts us all.
And if a Latino succeeds,
we all claim it.
We take the pride in
that, because we do.
However, that doesn't
mean that, if there's
a Latino at the head
of said studio, that's
going to translate to my
experience as a Latino
in their stories and
the stories they tell.
And so, you know, I have
tried from before I ever even
imagined myself a producer,
a 17-year-old kid trying
to talk to a film
studio about like,
don't market to
Latinos that way.
Because who you're
talking to is me,
and I grew up watching "Fresh
Prince of Bel Air" and "Family
Matters" and "Dawson's Creek."
And if you're looking for me,
then maybe listen a little bit
to the nuance of what
someone like me wants.
I want to see people who look
like me in all these stories,
in all these images.
But that doesn't
necessarily mean
that if you just throw the word
"telenovela" in it, I'm like,
that's me!
You know, that's-- I walked
out of the room if my mom put
on a telenovela.
I couldn't stand it.
Or, you know, if it's
just half in Spanish,
it's all of a sudden going to
appeal to all of the Latinos.
It will never
equal good business
to think of us as a monolith.
And that's why I think
that this term of Latinx--
which I think I may not
even understand fully,
so I would love kind
of a concise definition
of what Latinx means--
it has-- even as a producer,
even as a storyteller,
even as somebody who goes out
on a daily basis and speaks
to content makers about this
young group of Latinos who
identify themselves as not
the Latino that you have
in your mind--
it's given us agency and power
to delineate ourselves inside
of that monolith.
And there's power
in that when you're
having conversations about
storytelling and business
and nuance inside of a very,
very, very broad stroke.
That doesn't serve us when--
if you're a politician,
or if you're a businessman
genuinely trying to reach
a specific audience.
Because our experiences are so
vastly nuanced and different.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Andrew, do
you want to speak
about continuing
to embrace our nuances?
ANDREW HERRERA: Yeah.
I think there's one uniform
theme for all of us,
is that I think we're proud.
We're very proud of what
this culture represents.
I think we all have
different definitions
or have different experiences
on how that plays out.
And I think, for me
personally, I think, you know,
what I've created
was-- you know,
I created a forum that was out
of an identity crisis of me
wanting to not really
identify as a Latino.
And, you know, I
was born Andres,
and my name is Andrew today.
Why?
Because, in the 90s,
my name was "undress"
or "Andre as," and no one
knew how to-- and that was--
but today, Andres is cool.
And where I'm going with
this is that I think--
in today's environment,
I think I'm
starting to see more pride
than I've ever seen before.
And that didn't necessarily
come through labels.
I think that came
through the culture
evolving and the
influence that we've
had beyond our own
community, right?
Beyond kind of just
Hispanics, but how we see--
I think our non-Hispanic
friends embrace our own culture,
and I think that allows
us to also go down
this new path of having
an identity that, one, we
can be proud about.
Two, can continue to evolve.
And that isn't only
based off of race.
I mean, I-- you know,
it's pretty frustrating.
You know, one of
the reasons I do
what I do and I
love what I do is
because I get to
break stereotypes even
within my own community.
You know, for example, it's--
we talk about Afro-Latinos.
And it's something that
we talk about today,
but Afro-Latinos have been
part of the Hispanic community,
Latin community, Latinx
community for decades.
But you never saw
them on Univision.
You never saw them on Telemundo.
They were never
a representation.
I know a lot of friends that I
didn't even know were Latino.
That were basically assimilated
to African-American-- you know,
being--
calling themselves
African-American without
mentioning that they were
Latino, because that wasn't--
they didn't feel welcomed.
So I think-- but
today, we're starting
to see that evolve into
where they are welcomed,
or that we talk
about these issues
within our own community.
So I agree with some of what
you're saying, but I also--
but I disagree in
terms of it just
being about a label
that we get behind.
I think what we get behind
is that we are influencing
and that we want to
push others to be
more fluent in our culture, not
just in how people define us.
And I think if we
do that well, I
think this conversation goes
from actually not just being
an academic conversation
but a conversation that
goes into practice in terms
of how people make decisions.
Whether it be around
content, around--
you know, around-- I deal
with a lot of advertisers,
and it's like being
in the dark ages
sometimes about how they
want to chase and really
communicate with our community.
So I do hope that--
I think we do need
to embrace this time,
and I think the fact
today is that we
do have this great pride.
We do have this great diversity.
But I think we're
just beginning.
And I think we have to
embrace something like Latinx,
but embrace it for the people
that it means something for,
not put it as a label that a
group has to identify with.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
I'm going to switch
slightly away from the label.
I know we keep on revisiting it,
but it is such a salient topic,
and something that we do need
to discuss amongst ourselves,
and also for the
wonderful audience that's
watching us today.
But I want to pick up on
your comment around race
within the Latino community.
And we're not comfortable
talking about race
within the Latino community.
Racial hierarchy,
white privilege
within the Latino community.
And I'd love to hear
from all of you,
or if anyone in particular
who wants to speak about,
how does that show up for us?
And how has it shown up,
if at all, for any of you
individually?
AMERICA FERRERA: Well,
I think I started my--
the first thing I
said was very much
based on learning
what kind of Latino
was an OK Latino to be when
you were growing up in the San
Fernando Valley and seeing--
you know, seeing the
version of Latino that
was sort of dismissed
and stereotyped and put
in a certain box,
and not wanting
to be shoved in that box.
Therefore, trying to make
myself as different as possible.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ: Was
that because of socioeconomics
or because of race?
AMERICA FERRERA: I think it
was about a lot of stuff.
I think, for one, I think
race is a really, really
big part of that.
I think that-- I heard
a friend say this,
and it seems so true to me.
When people demonize or
don't like your Latino-ness,
it's not the European
part of your Latino-ness
they don't like.
It's the brown part.
It's the indigenous part.
And, I mean, I saw
a horrible example
of that on social media.
There was all kinds of
horrible things being
said during the Super Bowl,
and someone was talking about
like Gisele Bundchen being
Brazilian and people saying,
yeah, but she's white.
She's a white Brazilian.
And that's not Latino,
and therefore white people
are still supreme.
And that sort of stuff,
it's such a key reminder
of what we don't like to
discuss and talk about.
Which is-- is that race
plays such a huge part.
And, you know, I'll say it.
Like the older family
members I grew up
with spoke of black people
in the most demeaning ways.
You know?
Race was always a part
of the conversation.
And I remember--
I won't say who,
because I feel like
they'd be ashamed.
But an older person in
my family would always
say to my half white,
half Latina cousin,
come out of the
sun or you're going
to be dark like your cousins.
Or my mother would never ever
let me go out into the sun
without sunscreen, and a
hat, and, come out of there,
you don't want to look like--
you know, a campesina
or whatever.
We grew up with that constant
sort of injection of race
always, and skin color
being a part of a hierarchy.
And you wanted to be a
light skinned Latino.
You didn't want
to have an accent.
I mean, we grew up not
even speaking Spanish.
Because to speak
Spanish, I believe--
assuming the best of
my parents, they just
wanted the best for us.
So it was about
wanting to be perceived
as someone who could
take advantage of all
the opportunities and succeed.
And so much of that was
about stripping away
the parts of being Latino
that other people weren't
comfortable with.
And it was about other.
It was about be as much--
try to be as much
of a white person
as you can in America to
be a successful Latino.
And I've had to
reckon with that,
and think about how that
has shaped who I am,
and go on this journey of
learning that my value is
inherently there and not based
upon, you know, how appealing I
am to the people
in powerful rooms.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE], would you like to--
RHONDA GONZALEZ: Sure.
Well, I guess I'm one
of those people who
is not uncomfortable
talking about race at all.
But I do think that--
again, I think nuance of
language is important.
And I think we all need to
be reminded again and again
that when we're
talking about race,
we're talking about
large systems of power,
and not just individual
prejudices or biases,
and those kinds of things.
But I do think that there is
a deep historical and colonial
legacy that is part--
been referred to here.
And that is the
roots of Latinidad
is inclusive of Africans,
indigenous folks, and then
all kinds of Iberian people.
Really complicated as well
from the Iberian world.
And those colonial
legacies, in part,
JC mentioned, you see in access
to material wealth still today.
And those are like
the legacies we
see in especially Latin
American countries, when we're
talking about Latino nations.
And so there's that.
But I also think the
uncomfortable part is not
so much race as it is
the color discrimination,
or which is now, in the
literature, an evolving
field of colorism.
And that is-- and I won't
mention names either,
but the first time I went back
to East Texas-- my parents
migrated here in 1954.
And then, college graduation,
I had this really great idea.
I want to go see where I came,
where my parents came from.
And so took Mom back.
And they're in Texas,
where I am now.
And I love Texas.
But in East Texas,
you know-- and I
think a lot of maybe panelists
had this experience, where
you meet people you didn't know,
but they're related to you.
And what they want to
show you are the pictures
of their children who
married white people,
and their light
skinned grandchildren.
And these are the things
you hold up as a trophy
or as a point of pride, and
you don't see the others.
I mean, so that's like
kind of a familial context,
but I think the same thing
happens in our institutions.
I don't think it's
an accident that when
you look around institutions,
you see people in positions
of power who might be Latino.
That they may be fair skinned.
That they may look like the
more standard ideal of beauty--
European features,
whatever it might be.
You know, however that idea
is constructed in our minds.
And so I think there are
a lot of intersecting
points on this
topic, but I really
think that we could
really benefit
from talking more about colorism
and color discrimination.
Not just within
Latino communities--
because this affects every
community, Asian, white,
African-American, so
across the spectrum.
But I do think that's a
really important point.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you so much.
We have-- unless you
have any other points.
I have one-- I think--
JC, you look like you're
itching to answer that question.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: I'm so
excited about the Afro Latino
movement.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ: Yes?
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO:
I really am.
You know, as a Dominican--
and I mentioned this again--
if you ever want to study
a group of people that
are really conflicted,
92% of our people
have African descendancy.
We avoid it like
it's the plague.
For us to admit that
we have black in us?
Let me tell you.
You know this.
You know this, Daisy.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ: I'm
Dominican and Puerto Rican.
That's why he says.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: My kids are
too, so it's a real conflict.
Think about this.
We will mention every shade
before we accept blackness.
We will call ourselves
oat, dark oat,
burnt oat, light Indian, medium
Indian, dark Indian, light
chocolate.
You go down the list.
You never want to be
associated with being black.
And that was the concept
for a very, very long time.
I grew up-- and as
I mentioned earlier,
and I shared with you
that I am biracial.
But my entire family is
either white or black.
So we are that family.
We are that little
unit of people
that look like me, that
are accepted by one side
but not by the other too much.
And I'm sorry if you
watch and you get mad,
but you really didn't
accept me, guys.
But it's interesting.
And I want to share
something with you, because I
think history is so important.
Words matter.
Labels matter.
I got it.
There's a reason why
this is happening.
There's a reason why this is.
And if you study the
Latin American conquest,
you soon realize how important
it was, at one point,
for the Spanish landowner to
have a ratio on his plantation
that would be enough
master to slave
to be able to
control a rebellion.
And how it was, the reality,
that there was never
enough white slave masters.
And it's because of that.
That the white
slave master began--
not accepting citizens of
Spain, because you couldn't be,
but citizens of the land.
And Dr. Frank Moya Pons,
who is the authority when
it comes to the history
of the Dominican Republic,
really writes
clearly about this.
When he talks about
the fact that they
were forced to accept people
that were more like them
in hue, and have them want
to now be the overseers
and manage the other
black folk, that
created a sense of superiority
among those that appeared
to be more lighter in tone,
more European in tone,
and really created resentment
amongst many people that
wanted their children to
be the ones on the horse.
The one on the porch, the one
inside, the one not getting
raped and killed
in the plantation.
That reality, because
everything's historical,
affected people today.
And it's been ingrained in
so many Latinos not wanting
to accept their blackness.
I've written a lot about this.
I get really excited
about this topic.
So when I see African
descent Latinas no longer
feel the need that they need to
have their hair a certain way
and go through a
process of chemical
destruction of their follicles,
and accept their blackness.
And when I see them
say, I don't have
to get plastic
surgery on my nose.
When I hear them say, I'm black,
and I'm proud, and it's OK,
and yes, you can be
black and Latino.
Like you could be
a white American.
a black Frenchmen.
Like you can be a black Latino.
Like we could have Ricky
Martin and David Ortiz,
and they're both Latinos, right?
So it's a great
thing to talk about.
I'm really happy that you're
starting to write about
and people are talking about it.
And the Afro Latino
movement is very important.
Because a sense of self
inferiority is being diluted.
I'm really excited about it.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
Andrew, I keep on--
I want to call you
Andres, but I'm
going to stop myself from it.
Andrew, would you like to--
you've spoken about the work
that you're doing
around racial identity.
Is there anything else
you'd like to share?
ANDREW HERRERA: Sure.
I think, in terms of--
from an Afro-Latino
perspective, or from, you know--
I think it is--
it's gotten to be
very much a time
where I think we can have
these conversations today.
In terms of Afro
Latinidad, it's not just
with the Dominican Republic.
It's the entire region.
And I think, you know,
we need to push people
to be more fluent within
our community to actually
understand all of this.
I think, for example,
we talk about it here.
But I still think there
are people within--
whether it be
Google or whether it
be other places, people that
are in power and make decisions
that have no idea
that this is a thing.
So we talk about this
and it's a topic.
So I think--
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
How do we make it
less of a topic and more part
of the general conversation?
You You know, I
hope, with the way
we look at this
community in the future--
I don't know if that's
in the 2020 census, which
is supposed to evolve
in terms of having
more ways to look at how this
community identifies itself,
right?
I think there's a lot of
people like myself who--
you know, you have to check a
box of whether you're white,
black, or Asian or other.
And then you have a lot
of people that, you know,
are like me and will
probably pick white.
Because it's-- and I
think we need to give--
start moving in a
direction of having ways
that people can identify
themselves more accurately.
And not just more
accurately, but in a way that
is honest with how
they should feel
versus having to conform
one way or the other.
So I think this is a larger
to be continued discussion.
I'm just personally
excited about the fact
that we are talking about it.
I would hope that
even Hispanic media
outlets continue to embrace it.
I still don't see--
I see magazines that
represent Latinas,
and it's still
not really showing
the true diversity of race
within our own community.
You know, I think we're
in this point where
it's being redefined.
It's being-- it's not--
we're remixing the way--
I think we're breaking
the stereotypes every day.
So I think the great thing
about it is that it's being,
actually--
I think this is coming
out of our youth, right?
Pr coming out of the youth
wanting to understand.
Right?
I think they-- we have failed.
I think, in a way,
society has kind of
failed to give them a way to
embrace their own identity.
And now they're taking it--
you know, they're taking that--
you know, they're
taking leadership.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you so much.
We're about to--
I'm going to prep
the group here.
We're about to go
into live questions.
But before we do that, I want
to honor the HOLA community who
is here today.
HOLA is our employee
resource group
that is focused on
the Latino community,
both internally within
Google and externally.
And they do a lot
of amazing work--
volunteering, and tutoring,
and a host of other projects
locally here within LA.
And I'd love to go
quickly, before we
move into live questions.
So you can start lining
up for the live questions.
If you have any recommendations
to the HOLA community on what
they could do here
in the LA community,
or for the broader LA
community, to support our Latino
community.
AMERICA FERRERA: Well, I
think, in general, it's
really about letting people know
that there is space for them
inside of your community.
And I feel so
indebted to Remezcla
and other organizations,
group media
outlets like it, inviting
certain people who'd
never seen a space for them
inside of a certain community
to get to be a part
of it and claim it.
And, you know, you guys
are in the tech industry.
You're in a huge company.
And to just, as you are,
setting examples for people who
can reach this level of
being in the tech world,
but also reaching
out to the community
around these neighborhoods
that may never
ever see a space for themselves
inside of a place like Google.
I think that that really,
really makes a difference,
and it matters.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ: JC?
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: Well,
I got to meet Hector today.
And I think Hector
does a great job.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Yes, he does.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: I got
to meet the rest of the team.
I think it's great.
And I didn't know that there
were that many Hispanics
involved in this field.
So it's really interesting
to see the work
that you're doing to get
out there and get people
to know that, not
only you exist,
but that they can be part of it.
I think that the media has
to do a much better job
in putting this out
there and showing us
as computer engineers and people
involved in the tech field,
as you mentioned.
I never get to see us--
as you mentioned, I want
to see us everywhere.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMERICA FERRERA:
Tell more stories.
Tell me of our stories.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO:
This is very exciting.
So good to see you
and your group,
and you're doing
a really good job
by just even helping
organize these discussions.
ANDREW HERRERA: You know,
thank you for inviting me.
I think this is a
great discussion.
It's a complicated
discussion, but I
think complicated
discussions are positive.
I think one thing that
I would encourage--
you know, whether it be HOLA or
other Googlers-- is to really--
I think it's great to unite.
But we also need to figure
out how to be inclusive
around that discussion, right?
You know, I think that's
my fear with creating
an "us and them"
kind of discussion,
is that I don't think it
allows to be inclusive.
You know you, for example,
in the women's march,
there were thousands
and thousands
of men that wanted to
support that movement.
And I think there
are non-Latinos
that want to also support,
I think, our community.
And I think we just need to kind
of create ways for other people
to really support
this community.
So I think-- you know,
I think that would be--
I hope what organizations
start to do.
Because this has been
something-- you know,
diversity initiatives
have been going on
for a really long time.
But I think it needs to go
beyond the cafeteria having
Mexican food for Hispanic day.
I think it needs to be--
And this is what I still see
at major, major corporations.
And we need to do
the 2.0 of that.
And I think it has to be a
little bit more inclusive.
And I think people want-- and
I think we are living in an age
where there is this more
cultural fluency of people
that don't want to be-- that
are already embracing it
themselves.
And, you know, I think as long
as we continue to be inclusive,
I think that's the
right direction.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
RHONDA GONZALEZ: OK.
I want to just say, I don't
know what Google already does.
So this may be a
recommendation that you all
already take care of.
But in terms of demystifying
the Google entity,
I think definitely
bringing children here
to campus on the regular.
Like you can't do that enough.
Because just them
having been to visit
lets them imagine, you know,
when they see your Chrome
platform, that they
are within that wall,
I guess, so to speak.
And so I think just creating
those opportunities for them
to visit.
And secondly, I would say
within the institution is that--
really pay attention to
not just your practices,
but your policies
that you all establish
within your institution.
And that takes a
lot of vigilance
and a lot of attentiveness
to speaking out in the room.
And whether you're of an
identified group or an ally--
to use the word that
we now use so often--
to really speak up if
no one's there to speak,
and also to amplify
the voices in the room.
Because that's probably one
of the hardest things to do,
is to be the token in the
room and then have everybody
sit around like crickets
after you've made a point.
So if there's any inclination
to agree or appreciate
a perspective, please use your
voice to back that person up.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you all so much.
I actually wrote my question,
because I'm a little bit
nervous asking this.
So my name is Olga Garcia.
And, again, thank you
guys for being here.
So as a proud Latina,
Colombiana, HOLA Googler,
you know, your
voice really impacts
how our Googlers function.
So thank you.
And as an internal
advocacy group,
so HOLA, the thing that
we grapple with the most
is, how do we make sure that
our leadership understands
the urgency and advocates
for our Googlers
within our community at
Google as well as externally?
And so what advice do
you have for us, at HOLA,
to talk to our leaders?
To support our
Googlers, whether it's
taking a stance on immigration,
whether it's building products
for our community,
both internally
and externally to Google, or
having more leaders like Daisy,
at the senior level,
representing and giving us
an example that we can
aspire to be like Daisy?
ANDREW HERRERA: That's
an interesting question.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
You've stomped the panel.
RHONDA GONZALEZ: I guess--
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: All
I heard was [INAUDIBLE].
RHONDA GONZALEZ: Well,
I feel like it picked up
a little bit maybe on the
point I was trying to make.
Earlier But, for me, the
bottom line is persistence.
Refuse to forget an idea.
You know, if you have a
good idea, stick with it.
Talk to people until people are
just tired of hearing about it.
Right?
Because I think that whatever's
in you and whatever HOLA,
your vision is, that I'm
sure it's worthwhile, right?
So you want to continue.
It may take 10 years.
10 years to push to a
point where you actually
see something happen.
And I think one of the
things we're not used to
is that delayed
gratification, right?
We want instant, click
a button, it happens.
And I think that
this is where you
know the realness
of humanity comes
in is that it takes a lot of
time to steer the barge, right?
To really get it in a direction.
But don't give up.
Because, you know, what happens
is that once you get there,
it starts to snowball.
And so that 50 years from now,
100 years from now, the legacy
is that there is so much
representation in Google.
So you may not even
see it-- sorry to say--
in your lifetimes, right?
But you know that
you're leaving--
opening up that space
for a legacy to evolve.
AMERICA FERRERA: I would
love to add to that.
We have these conversations
all the time as content makers
in Hollywood, this conversation
about diversity, diversity.
What's the answer?
And, you know, I think
on a very personal level,
how we approach the
conversation really matters.
And I think removing shame and
blame from the conversation
is a really, really
important piece of it.
Because if we can remove
the personal blame of,
there aren't Latinos here
because you don't care,
then we can remove the defenses.
And we can all sort of
ask ourselves, how do I--
how am I contributing
to the way things are?
And I'm not-- we
all think, you know,
if there's a bunch of bad evil
people trying to keep diversity
from happening, well,
I'm not that evil person,
so I'm not the problem.
But if we remove
that myth, that it--
you know, that it's bad
because people are bad--
then we can start
having the conversation
that we all have a role to play.
And approaching the
conversation with allies,
from a place of
finding solutions,
and a place of positivity,
and a place of excitement
and what we all have to gain.
And I would say, removing
the stigma and the shame of,
there's something
wrong and it's wrong
because you're not doing it.
It may open the conversation
up for more engagement
from many people.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
RHONDA GONZALEZ: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you guys so much.
So my question is
around-- and I really
appreciate the
honesty with which
you shared some of the
anti-blackness that exists
within Hispanic communities.
Because I feel like this
is something that we know
is kind of consistent
and pervasive
across communities-- white
communities, Asian communities,
even within black
communities there's colorism.
So I guess one question
that I have is,
what organizations,
or what work do
you feel like is being
done with young Hispanics
and young Latinos to combat
that so that we don't take it
forward?
And then what
promise really lies
in true ally-ship between
black and brown communities
in the US, and how
do we get there?
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO:
That's a great question.
You know, I'm a teacher.
I started in the public
schools, not too far
from where you're
from, in the Bronx?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO:
Truman High School?
AUDIENCE: Shout out.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: Shout out.
And I think there's no better
organization than a school
to start that difference.
I really do.
In my heart, I feel it.
I know that there's no
better place than a classroom
to have a teacher that
understands the topic.
That understands
the differences,
that understands
the issue, and is
able to facilitate a discussion
and change hearts and minds
and bring people together.
So you mentioned organizations.
I'm thinking Truman High School.
I'm thinking Borough of
Manhattan Community College.
I'm thinking PS85
on Valentine Avenue.
These are all areas where
incredible things can happen
if the teacher is well equipped
to be able to facilitate
that kind of discussion.
I'm hopeful that you're going
to see-- because of Andres
And the good work he's
doing at Remezcla,
you're going to
see more and more
people feel comfortable having
the discussion about blackness
in our communities and the
commonalities that exist.
So I'm really excited
to see that happen.
RHONDA GONZALEZ: I just wanted
to add a little bit that
may be a little bit surprising,
but there's actually
been a lot of work on this
kind of topic among scholars.
In some ways, maybe there is--
we're a little bit
behind the times
when it comes to the
scholarship that's out there.
And I think part of
why we don't really
know about a lot of the
allyships that have gone on
across US history is that
much of that scholarship
isn't in the foreground of
traditional departments.
And so this is
why, for people who
are in the conversation about
de-funding Chicano studies,
or de-funding Latino studies,
or African American studies,
Pan-African studies,
Asian studies, LGBTQ
and queer studies,
I mean, this is
where that breaking-- that
scholarship has resided.
And so there are a
number of scholars.
I can give names later.
But there is
scholarship out there
that has talked about
precedent for these allies.
And I think that--
these alliances, rather.
But I do think that right
now, because of the shifting
demographics of the nation that
they're-- it's all the more
critical that
Latinos especially,
or Latinx's, especially, create
a very conscientious outreach
to our brothers and sisters
who may be excluded,
or may be without any
intentionality toward it from
a national shifting
conversation.
AMERICA FERRERA: I
would love to add
to that I think leadership
really matters as well.
I think convening people
who are already established,
trusted voices in
their community
to exemplify and model
building those bridges.
My husband and I started
sort of a convening and--
not "sort of"-- a convening
of influencers and people
in organizations.
And what we try to do
in those conversations
is draw what aligns us.
You know, bring that out.
And to hear someone from--
a co-founder of
Black Lives Matter
say that DACA students showed
up for Black Lives Matter.
And so Black Lives Matter,
they show up for DACA.
Or DACA and Black Lives Matter.
We're on the front
lines at Standing Rock,
with the Native American
youth leadership.
Leadership really matters and
exemplifying, especially today,
that we see our
struggles inside of one
another's struggles
I think really
makes a difference and
matters, especially when
you talk about setting
an example for our youth,
and our young people,
and whether or not
they can see themselves in
each other's experiences.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
I'm going to move over
to the Dory for a bit.
We have we have quite
a few questions,
so I'll do the first two
and then move live here.
The first one is from Marrissa.
Using Crenshaw's theory
of intersectionality,
we place excluded
groups at the center
of analysis, which helps us
see that hierarchies are not
absolute, but relative.
How do we recognize the
matrix-like interaction
of race, gender, social
class and upward mobility
within the Latinx community?
[LAUGHTER]
These are light questions.
RHONDA GONZALEZ: OK.
From the professor, I'm going
to say read a lot, right?
Read.
Read deeply.
Read deeply instead
of just broadly.
You know, really read deeply.
But I also think that this
gets to the kind of climate
that I think really pervades
our nation, as it's kind
of an anti-intellectualism.
And I think that embracing
the idea of intellectualism
means that, of course we
deal with these complicated
intersections.
That not only do
we deal with them,
but we actually
should thrive on them.
I often tell my
students, because I
teach African history,
that, in this classroom,
we embody a Nigerian
cafe environment.
So, you know, if you were
to walk into a coffee
shop in Nigeria, people are
engaged in a really vigorous
discussion and
debate, but really
for not so much winning
a debate, right?
But for the collective
understanding and the growth
that comes out of debates.
So I really think
that that's one way.
AMERICA FERRERA: An
idea came to mind.
You know, I heard earlier
that, within Google, you
have all these groups.
You have HOLA, you
have the black network.
And that's an opportunity
inside of Google for you all
to start building bridges,
and finding intersectionality,
and showing up for one
another's conversations,
and modeling how we begin
to find what aligns us.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
ANDREW HERRERA: Yeah, I
was just going to add--
I mean, that's a great segue.
I mean, one of our
most successful pieces
was on how Filipinos
are our cousins,
are our Latino cousins.
And actually, it went viral.
And those are the types
of things where, you know,
what aligns us is actually what
is able to create a stronger
message.
So, and, you know, I think
I would continue down
that road of--
I think there's a lot of
youth that are trying to,
whether it be on
political issues,
to kind of depoliticize
the conversation.
It's happening in music.
It's happening in people
creating great content, where
people are collaborating and
adding their own nuance to it.
And so I think, in terms of--
at Google, I think
you could also--
I wanted to enter on
the last question.
I think you guys
should definitely
feel entrepreneurial.
Don't wait for the
organization to change.
Be part of the change.
And whether that be within
an official Google--
you know, Google organization,
you can do that on your own
and be entrepreneurial
with that.
And, you know, I think--
we're a culture that's
pretty scrappy in terms
of how we evolve and how
we achieve great things.
I think taking that into--
as a way to create
change, I think,
was something I would recommend.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
Googlers, get scrappy.
All right?
Selena, from Austin, asks,
how do we support each other
within the Latinx community and
across the various backgrounds
that make up Latinx
in a way that
allows us to break down the
pre-established structures
of discrimination?
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO:
I don't understand.
The question regarding
discrimination in the United
States, and how it's--
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Across-- yeah,
how do we support each
other within the community,
and across our
various backgrounds--
intersectionalities, I'm
going to understand--
that allows us to break down
pre-established structures
of discrimination?
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: Well, I
think there's a lot going on.
I do.
I think there are
a lot of movements.
I think that the
election of-- and I
know that there are lot
of people that disagree
with me, especially on my side.
I think that the election
of President Obama
did a lot to tear down some
of those walls of things
that we thought were
impossible, of groups
of people that we thought
would never come together.
I think that a lot
has already happened.
A lot has been written.
A lot has been discussed.
And I think we can
learn from that.
And I think we
can say, you know,
this election of President
Obama has created an environment
where a lot of the
vestiges of discrimination
may be breaking down.
So I know he's not
in office anymore,
and I know a lot of my friends
are very sad about that.
But I think it's an
opportunity for you
to see, what is the vestige of--
what is the legacy of President
Obama?
And I'm asking you
as a Republican.
What is the legacy behind--
is it just Obamacare?
I think there's more.
I think that the
legacy has to be
how many of these walls
that we had before
may not be perfectly torn down.
There may be some
bricks up there still.
But a lot of them
have come down.
And I think that the person
that asked the question
has to just realize that
we are in a new age.
And there is discrimination,
but not even close
to how it used to be.
I think
AMERICA FERRERA: I think on
a very, very basic level,
it's that you have to do
something for someone else,
wherever you are.
If you've reached a position
of influence or power
or privilege, even if that means
you've found a way to graduate
high school, in a community
where people don't know how
to graduate high school,
or can't get through it,
turn around and figure out
a way to open that door
or remove a barrier for someone
else to come in behind you.
I know my career would
not have been possible
five years before it began.
You know, I came
around and I had--
it was a perfect confluence
of a million things
that allowed me to get to step
in and take that opportunity.
That doesn't mean there
weren't hundreds or thousands
of other people who could
have just as easily taken
that opportunity.
And now I have access because
other people created access
for me.
And so wherever we are, in
whatever industry we work in,
whatever privileges we've
had in our lives, especially
people who work
at Google, we have
to understand that
we are the ones that
are going to be able
to open that door
for that next generation.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Live question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I've noticed, at least in
the kind of white culture,
if there's an indigenous
person from Mexico in the US,
they're a Latino, Latinx.
If they're an indigenous
person from America,
they're a Native American.
And they're not Latino.
Why does Native American
seem to be this kind
of different group from Latino?
Do you agree with that?
I mean, I don't--
as I said, that's kind
of the stereotype.
But do you see Native
Americans as part of Latino?
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: I am a
firm believer that you can
be many things and be Latino.
And I think that when you
think about Native Americans--
and I have this
discussion in my class.
When you think about the Native
American nations that existed,
and how so many of
them are located
in what we call the
United States today,
at one point were part
of the Spanish conquest,
those people today are Latinos,
and they are Native American.
And you can be both.
I don't think it's
one or the other.
I think that it's time that we
as Latin Americans or Americans
of Latino descent understand
that there are millions
of our people in
the United States
that are in fact
Native Americans.
They may speak Spanish
and have Spanish surnames,
and share in our
Latino identity,
but I think both of
them are coexistent.
AMERICA FERRERA:
You know, I think
this goes back to sort of
one of the first things
we were talking about, like
identification, and labels,
and why they matter.
And, you know, the
truth is, as a Latina,
I never thought to think of
myself as an indigenous person.
And I've actually
heard of conversations
amongst Native American thought
leaders about this concept
of indigenousness and how Latino
Americans have been completely
ripped from their indigenousness
and don't claim that
and don't identify
themselves, and how powerful
would that be if we could
find a way to merge, you know,
our efforts and see ourselves
in our Native American brothers
and sisters, as related
through our indigenousness?
And I think there's an
incredibly powerful thought
in there, that I've only
recently begun to even
hear be verbalized outside of
academic or scholarly worlds,
where I'm sure it probably
has been discussed.
ANDREW HERRERA: I mean, there
are indigenous communities
that I would say, in Latin
America and South America,
that wouldn't identify
themselves as Latinos.
So I think that's one--
you know, actually
to be accurate about kind
of that that labeling again.
So I think we need to
understand that piece.
You know, obviously,
from my skin color,
there is an
indigenous side of me.
But there are communities
that still don't.
So I think we need to
be conscious of the fact
that I think there's that same
issue that Native Americans
have that also exist in Latin
America, where they actually
don't even speak Spanish.
So they've actually continued
to live out their independence.
In Ecuador and Peru,
they speak Quechua.
And that's a language that is
not at all tied to Spanish.
RHONDA GONZALEZ: I think--
the small comment
I'll make I think
is about the politics
of indigeneity
and the claims of it is tied
to the nation, and the nation's
history, right?
So in our context
here in North America,
the idea of indigeneity
and indigenous populations,
Native Americans, I mean, this
is their land that was taken,
given back.
Now they're, for all
intents and purposes,
in an apartheid structure in
the state, in this country.
But I also think the politics
of being Latina or Latino,
and within that
context, has created--
part of what we're
really talking about
is that many Latinos
feel like they
live in this sort
of liminal space,
or the interstitial spaces,
if you get into theory
about what that means.
And that is neither being
of here or there, right?
So you're kind of
like without a nation.
And so I think part of this
complexity and nuance--
because we are everywhere,
and yet this is not ours.
And especially when
we have leadership
at the political level, speaking
as if we don't belong here,
even though, for many of
us, our roots go very deep.
So I think there's-- it's a
really complicated answer,
but I do think it's tied up
in the politics of the history
of this nation in particular.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: So in the
political events
that have been happening in
the US and many countries
in Europe, if there is a
political philosophy that
is articulated, to the
extent that it's articulated,
it's that strong nations
have to be homogeneous.
That there has to be--
which, de facto, means a white,
you know, European culture.
And so you have to strip
any part-- to be successful,
to be a part of
that society-- you
have to strip anything
that doesn't fit in that.
How do we best counter
that narrative?
How do we advance
a narrative where
a pluralistic diverse society,
where there is no majority,
is not threatening and is a
positive feature-- future.
How do we articulate that?
How do we counter
that narrative?
RHONDA GONZALEZ: I would ask for
the evidence of that statement.
AUDIENCE: Which, what--
RHONDA GONZALEZ: What's the
evidence that they would
use to support that position?
I can say anything, but
what's your evidence?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We're kind of post
evidence, at this--
[LAUGHTER]
RHONDA GONZALEZ:
Insist on evidence.
AMERICA FERRERA:
I mean, what comes
to mind for me is,
in my conversations
with my friends involved in the
Black Lives Matter movement,
is that they are doing
just that and also facing
a lot of backlash for it.
You know, they talk a
lot about their movement
in relation to the
civil rights movement
and how a big part
of the civil rights
movement for black people was
to kind of dress a certain way,
and look a certain way,
and talk a certain way,
so that there would be
success for the movement.
And my understanding is
that Black Lives Matter
wants to bring exactly
who they are and not
have to strip away their culture
to be successful as a movement
inside of America.
But it's created a
lot of controversy.
And so, you know, identifying
where that conversation is
happening and where
people are actually
daring to step out and
model that, I think
we need to turn
our focus to that,
and pay attention, and
support and amplify.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: I
wanted to add to that.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Tom.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: Tom.
I think your
question deals with--
and I don't know if Google's a
political environment or not.
But I think we're
tiptoeing around--
tell me what you
really want to say.
Ask the question
that you're feeling.
Because I feel like
you're dancing around it,
and we're limited in the
answer that we may have.
Is your concern the
election of Donald Trump?
Is that what it is?
Is creating an
environment where you
think that you have to
have a homogeneous country?
Is that what you're getting at?
AUDIENCE: It's not just--
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO:
So talk to me.
AUDIENCE: I don't think
it's just Donald Trump.
But I do that's what's
behind closing the walls.
You know, keeping
the brown population,
like not letting it dilute.
The controversies of
speaking-- of teaching
Spanish in California schools,
which finally just got
repealed.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: But it's also what's
happening in the Netherlands,
in Brexit, in--
AUDIENCE: Marine LePen.
AUDIENCE: I don't
think it's just--
yeah, yeah.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO:
It's interesting.
I come from a world of politics.
I don't come from
the tech world.
So this is my life.
This is what I deal with.
And as someone intimately
involved in the party that won,
I know firsthand
the conversations
that are happening.
And I have to push
back just a little bit.
Not everyone that supports the
idea of having a wall, that
supports the idea of
having legal immigration,
or deporting some very,
very terrible people,
subscribes to the idea that
we have to be homogeneous.
And I think that there
are a lot of people
that actually want to see a
more nationalist approach.
That are in fact not
even close to what
you may be thinking they are.
And they feel as if they've been
created into a class of bigots.
I know them, because
I work with them.
I know them because
they're my friends.
I know them because they
voted for Obama in 2008.
And they voted for
him again in 2012.
And they don't exactly
see the country
as having to be
homogeneous, they just
view that their country
should be a country of laws
where the laws are respected.
And this issue of immigration
is such a delicate one.
Because yes, in
fact, you can respect
undocumented immigrants.
You can say that the
overwhelming majority of them
are wonderful human beings.
And you can never speak
about them the way you did,
Mr. Trump.
But at the same time say,
we are a nation of laws.
And there is a problem with
undocumented immigration
in some places.
And then you can have
that honest discussion
without feeling as if the
country must look the same way.
And too many people, I
think, feel as if they've
been put in a class of bigots.
And they're very,
very upset about it.
I speak to them, and I think we
have to change the conversation
and change the tone, I think.
I know I'm in the minority
of people when I say that.
Because if not,
there can't be unity
when you have a group of people
that have been castigated
as bigots when they're not.
And I'm very concerned
about the idea
of having a homogeneous
society when that's not
in fact what so many people
that supported the Trump agenda,
if you will, were behind.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: If I can
respond to that.
So if I heard conversations
about immigration
that were more in
that reasonable tone,
then I would find
it easier to believe
that that's the motivation.
But it always-- and
not just in the US,
it's in other countries-- it's
always associated with fear
mongering, and putting
down certain groups,
and that they're
dangerous and so on.
So I mean, that's--
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO:
I understand.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Those who couldn't hear,
the person behind said, can
we build a wall in Canada.
It's not just Mexico.
We're going to move--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you so much.
Please, Andrew.
ANDREW HERRERA: Oh, no.
I was going to say, you know,
when you don't have evidence,
you use fear.
And I think that's what's
been happening-- you know,
whether it be in Brexit or
whether it be here I think,
you know, there's this
fear of immigrants,
or fear of Syrians or
fear of these things.
And they're instilling fear
with people that, you know,
aren't really asking
for the evidence.
And I think,
unfortunately, the only way
to fight that is to protest.
Is to fight--
You know, I think, it isn't
about when they go high--
when they go low, we go high.
I think we have to actually
go with really fighting
those types of messages in a
louder and a more aggressive
way.
I think, you know, I've never
seen the amount of voices
out there protesting in the
streets in my entire life.
And I'm actually glad
that we're doing it,
because when we don't do
it, this is what happens.
People can come in
with no evidence
and actually instill
fear in people.
JUAN CARLOS POLANCO: Sorry,
you keep saying no evidence.
I keep hearing--
there is evidence.
There is evidence of
problems in countries
that have unlimited amounts
of undocumented immigration.
There is.
When you look at Europe and you
look at some of the countries
that Tom was talking about, we
have to turn on the TV and see
what happens in Nice and
see what happens in Paris,
and you begin to see that,
because of the porous borders
in many of these countries,
you're going to have people
that you cannot ascertain they
are creating havoc and creating
fear among the
people in that group.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ: I'm
going to let Andrew respond
to that, JC, and then
we're going to move on
to the next question.
ANDREW HERRERA: When we're
talking about evidence
it's, the people that
are voting on this
are people that don't know
immigrants, that have never--
that don't know a
Syrian, that don't have
this issue in their own homes.
And the people that are voting
against what this presidency is
about are people that live
within this community.
So I think when it goes
back to, if we do live
in a true democracy,
let's not instill fear
with the people that actually
don't actually live--
aren't actually having to--
you know, have to
deal with these issues
that we have to deal with.
And, I would say,
in New York, it's
a very different
environment than if I
were in rural America.
But that's why we're instilling
fear over immigration.
That's why we're instilling
fear over terrorism.
You know, I don't think that--
I think that's not necessarily
a straight forward conversation
about--
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ: Yeah.
And we can go on on
this conversation,
and I appreciate your comments.
We have one last question, and
we're going to have to close.
But thank you so much for that
commentary and the question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Monica Marquez, and
thank you all for being here.
I work here at Google
in the diversity space,
along with Daisy.
And my team advises all of
the employee resource groups
like HOLA and BGN and others.
And one of the things
that-- and I've
worked at other
institutions, as well.
But one of the things that--
they all do wonderful,
really great work.
And I think HOLA is doing a
really, really amazing job,
as all the other employee
resource groups are.
But what I've noticed--
and something that resonated
with me not too long ago--
is that they were working
on some of their stances
on really wanting Google to
take a stance on immigration,
and that voice, and all of this.
But one of the
things that they said
is, our voice isn't as loud
as the Black Lives Matter.
And one of those
things is, I've noticed
that a lot of the
black communities,
and the black movement, has a
really loud, amplified voice.
And there is a lot of really
great work of the Latinos
here within Google
doing work, but how
do we amplify that voice?
And it's not just here.
Sometimes we see it
externally, where
you might see so
much more coverage
on the black movements.
Or it's just much
louder and amplified.
And that might just
be a perception,
but perception is reality.
So how do we empower--
and sometimes it might
be cultural, right?
We try not to create
a lot of waves,
or ruffle too many
feathers, or we
try to be much more
collaborative about it, where
some communities just do
it and apologize later.
How do we get our
Latinos to really
kind of take that stance,
and just amplify that voice,
and not be worried about
the backlash, like you said,
where they kind of
just take that stance?
So I'm just trying
to grapple with,
how do we get our Latino group,
the HOLA, to kind of really
amplify that voice the
way that their other peers
and colleagues are doing?
RHONDA GONZALEZ: That's a
really beautiful question,
I have to say.
It's a really, really important
one, and I love those pants,
and I'm taking them from her.
No, I'm just kidding.
They're great.
So--
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ: In Latino
culture, you say [INAUDIBLE].
Which means that, anytime
you want to borrow them.
RHONDA GONZALEZ: OK, OK.
But I think part
of that question
about being emboldened, and
maybe being a little bit
careful, and trepidatious
is anchored in the fact
that, in some ways,
we have privilege.
In some ways, we
are not of here.
Because we talk about
that [INAUDIBLE].
So it's like a very
precarious kind of history
that we all, I think--
at least when we reach a
certain level of consciousness
or understanding, that
if we're too loud,
there might be backlash
against undocumented friends,
their communities.
Or maybe people
will talk about how,
you're not from here anyway.
I mean, even though
we may be of here.
But I also-- and then, with
black history, for all of its--
you know, the awful
tragedy of it--
there is a collective
identity anchored
in that experience of the
transatlantic slave trade,
right?
And for people who are
descendants of that.
And so there is a
collective identity
shaped by that long enduring
history which is very powerful.
Whereas we're talking
about 26 identities
that we talk about
that are in conflict.
And that's not to say
Africans aren't diverse,
or even in that original
experience of 400 years ago
and onward.
But there is something
about the history
that needs to be
understood, I think,
in that collective voice.
And the other thing is that--
maybe you touched on this,
the idea of respectability?
You know, like not
wanting to step on toes
and maybe being demure.
And I think that, from what
I've seen in not just the Black
Lives Matter movement of
the last couple of years.
But, you know, if you go back
to read Du Bois and more,
you see that there
is a certain idea of,
if we're going to
be respectable,
we're not really pushing
against status quo.
And if we're going to
push against status--
we need to push against
status quo if we want change.
And that's really
just the bottom line.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
America, you
look like you want
to say something.
AMERICA FERRERA: Yeah, I
do want to say something.
You know, I think too what's
so hard about right now
is that we're labeling things
political which actually
are not just political.
They're about value systems,
and they're about humanity.
And I think the more we can
message the values and say,
you know, it's one
thing to ask Google
to take a stance on
immigration reform,
it's another thing to ask Google
to stand up for the kids who
are being bullied
in their schools,
for the violence
that is happening
towards our communities.
Regardless of intent
of the conversations,
the outcome is such that
people feel emboldened
to attack our children
in schools, verbally
or physically, and we can't
stand for that value system.
And I think that is where
our alliances help us.
There is safety in numbers.
So if it's not just the
Latino group saying,
Google, we want you to stand
up for our communities,
find alliances.
Because you know what?
Muslim kids are
being attacked, too.
And black kids are
And gay kids are
being attacked, too.
So finding the
strength in numbers
and emboldening yourselves
around your value system,
and then asking Google
to make a decision
about where their values lie.
And try to remove the political
out of it, which is nearly
impossible in this day and age.
But I think we are at an
unprecedented moment in history
where it's about humanity.
And we can talk around
politics all we want.
But at the end of the
day, people's lives
have been made vulnerable.
And what Google
does today matters.
What Google and corporations
and companies like it,
where they stand and how they
choose to use their influence
and voice, will define
the world that we
live in in 15 and 20
years, and the world
that our kids grow up in.
And holding them to
their value system.
And you're going
to piss people off.
And it's not going
to be happy go lucky,
you know, let's all
sit around and have
a conversation about it.
You're going to have
to be willing to know
that not everyone is going
to be happy about it.
DAISY AUGER-DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
We are well above our time,
so we're going to close.
I think that--
I'm deeply thankful,
grateful for you to have come
and helped us have
this conversation
with Google, and eventually
outside of Google.
I think what we've
heard, consistently
and repeatedly, is
that words matter.
Labels matter.
Values matter.
We are at a really critical and
exciting time for the Latino,
Hispanic, Chicano.
Whatever whatever name we
want to use, but this richly
diverse community, there
is tremendous pride,
and there's tremendous
influence that's
coming from this community.
As Googlers, we're
incredibly privileged,
and we struggle
with our privilege.
But it's also a privilege that
we want to share and expand.
And we have unique
opportunities and great lessons
that we've learned here today.
As I'm as I'm looking
through my notes,
I'm thinking about the
challenges of bringing together
one--
you know, 26
different identities
into one shared platform.
But the opportunities
that come from that.
And I know that
we're ready for that.
And so I want to thank America,
JC, Andrew, Dr. Gonzalez.
Thank you so much, on
behalf of all Googlers here.
And we hope to continue
this conversation.
[APPLAUSE]